gestern hat das weltraum unternehmen
spacex etwas geschafft das sogar die
nasa höchstpersönlich für unmöglich
gehalten hat eine falcon 9 rakete
startete setzte 11 satelliten in der
erdumlaufbahn aus und landete
schließlich wieder sicher auf der erde
warum das so spektakuläre neuigkeiten
sind erfahrt ihr jetzt in diesem video
es war ein besonders wichtiger tag für
spacex und firmen gründer elon musk
nicht nur versucht das unternehmen schon
seit circa einem jahr eine rakete wieder
sicher landen zu lassen und ist dabei
bereits dreimal gescheitert
der letzte raketenstart im juni diesen
jahres verlief auch noch katastrophal
nachdem spacex über 20 starts
hintereinander ohne probleme über die
bühne gebracht hat die erfolgsserie war
also gebrochen
und obwohl die landungen auf hoher see
immer nur experimente und nie die
hauptmission waren stieg der druck auf
das unternehmen
also startete um halb neun abends
ortszeit in cape canaveral florida
die falcon 9 rakete sie flog mehrere
minuten lang über 200 kilometer richtung
weltall bis sich die erste stufe von der
zweiten trennte die zweite machte sich
weiter auf den weg richtung
erdumlaufbahn wo dann für einen
auftraggeber 11 satelliten ausgesetzt
wurden und die hauptmissionen
erfolgreich abgeschlossen wurde
diese auftragsarbeiten macht beim sex
schon lange und damit verdient sich das
unternehmen die brötchen aber nun zum
experimentellen und vor allem spannenden
teil nämlich der nebenmission die erste
stufe einer rakete in der sich zum
beispiel der booster und der große tank
befinden ist der wertvollere teil einer
rakete dieser drehte sich nach der
trennung und begann wieder richtung erde
zu fallen
mit kontrollierten buß landete die
rakete sicher auf dem erdboden
zirka zehn kilometer vom startpunkt
entfernt mitten auf einem riesigen iks
in der animation ist die rakete übrigens
ein bleistift weil die proportionen
dieser landung so sind wie ein bleistift
den man über das empire state building
wirft und der dann aufrecht in einem
schuhkarton landen soll
es ist ein unglaublicher balanciert eine
rakete wieder sicher auf der erde landen
zu lassen
viele macht selber vergleicht es mit
einem bleistift den mann während eines
wirbelsturms auf der fingerspitze
balancieren soll
und ich kann das nicht mehr ohne
wirbelsturm sogar die nasa ist vor
einigen jahren und nach einigen
überlegungen und prüfungen zu dem
schluss gekommen das ist viel zu
schwierig wäre eine rakete sicher auf
der erde landen zu lassen jetzt schon
einige sagen aber genau das hat doch vor
kurzem blue origin gemacht und das
stimmt auch teilweise blue origin ist
ein amerikanisches unternehmen mit dem
ziel weltraumtourismus zu betreiben
am 23 november hat die firma eine
unbemannte rakete circa 100 kilometer in
die luft befördert und die rakete wieder
sicher auf dem boden landen lassen
mit 100 kilometern höhe haben die
wissenschaftler übrigens exakt die
offizielle grenze zum weltraum
überschritten
das ist definitiv eine schwierige
aufgabe und man sollte auch blue origin
gratulieren
aber es liegen welten zwischen den
beiden versuchen eine rakete in den
weltraum zu befördern und etwas in die
umlaufbahn zu bringen sind komplett
unterschiedliche dinge zum einen ist die
space extrakte viel größer und schwerer
und war mehr als doppelt so weit von der
erde entfernt aber was noch viel
wichtiger ist sie hatte eine
geschwindigkeit zur seite ein kritischer
faktor um in die erdumlaufbahn zu kommen
was viele menschen nicht wissen ist dass
das schwierigste an einem raketenstart
nicht die höhe ist sondern die
geschwindigkeit parallel zum erdboden
die einst es kann nur um die erde
kreisen weil sie so eine hohe
geschwindigkeit zur seite hat und quasi
zu jedem zeitpunkt an der erde vorbei
feld ohne diese geschwindigkeit wurde
sie langsam aber sicher auf die erde
zurück fallen die schwierigkeit der
beiden versuche wurde mit dem einparken
eines gefährts verglichen
während viele maske einen suv rückwärts
eingeparkt hat hat blue origin ein
fahrrad angekettet das haben experten
gesagt übrigens gradlinig nach oben zu
fliegen und wieder zu landen ist etwas
das basic schon seit langem mit ihren
grasshopper tests gemacht haben
aber warum die ganze aufregung dann ist
die rakete halt eben wieder auf der erde
gelandet und jetzt naja jetzt sofort
noch nicht aber auf dauer ist das die
zukunft der raumfahrt
stellt euch vor ihr fliegt in den urlaub
und nach jeder landung wird das flugzeug
komplett zerstört und ein neues muss
gebaut werden
jedes ticket würde dann über 15
millionen euro kosten
und genau das passiert gerade in der
weltraumfahrt bei spacex kostet ein
raketenstart moment ca 60 millionen
us-dollar und das meiste davon geht
drauf um eine neue rakete zu bauen wenn
man eine rakete aber wieder verwenden
könnte dann würden die kosten auf den
treibstoff und ein paar reparaturen
sinken
jetzt muss beim sex natürlich erstmal
beweisen dass sie eine rakete die
bereits im all war wieder verwenden
können
die unglaublichen temperaturschwankungen
und belastungen bei einem start nehmen
raketen natürlich ordentlich mit
die falcon 9 rakete von gestern wird
übrigens nie wieder fliegen
zu hoch sei der emotionale wert der
ersten sicheren landung des unternehmens
ob das nun wirklich stimmt oder ob mit
der rakete vielleicht etwas nicht in
ordnung ist werden wir wahrscheinlich
nie erfahren wenn die lande technik in
vielen jahren ausgereift ist und man für
einen raketenstart irgendwann nur noch
ein zehntel der 60 millionen dollar
zahlen müsste dann könnten wir mehr
satelliten mehr sondern und mehr
menschen ins all bringen und spacex
könnt ihr ultimatives ziel erreichen den
mars zu bevölkern und so komisch das
auch klingt den mars zu befördern könnte
uns als menschheit das überleben sichern
wie das funktioniert habe ich in diesem
video erklärt müssen wir alle sterben
schaut euch an um mehr über das thema zu
erfahren und wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr über
einen daumen nach oben freuen und wenn
ihr freunde oder bekannte kennt denen
das video hier gefallen könnte dann
teilt das gerne über facebook oder wachs
ich wahrscheinlich hier in die
weihnachtsferien ich wünsche euch viel
spaß an weihnachten mit auch in familien
ist nicht zu viel bei oma und ansonsten
wünsche ich frohe weihnachten